tout le monde sait ce que weezy et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve comme promis
sur une nouvelle version thunder qui
s'appelle sanatorium j'ai juste baisse
un peu parce que là ça me pète les
oreilles donc vous m'avez envoyé deux
versions auspices et sanatorium j'avais
que pas mal de vidéos sur auspices et un
peu moins sur cet homme
donc j'ai choisi celle cible ou une page
naaqoos comme hambourg abris comme ça
mais je crois qu'on y aller en douceur
ne se cache pas dans la machine à laver
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça à ce jeu
c'est la whey ok bon c'est [ __ ] de
glauque s'il est là oh [ __ ] j'aime pas
ça ah là là autant le premier sneijder
s'est ouvert au temps au temps là c'est
comment faire mais ça veut dire que si
tu croises effectué situe probablement
marc à 300 bon sens mais rien n'est sûr
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
voilà je vous avoue que j'ai peur cela
fait quand même plus peur que l'olivier
ramène au temps l'autre tu vois rien tu
aurais guerre entre les arbres autant là
tu t'attends justement ce qu'il
apparaisse d'un goût si on peut parler
sa part de should be millions d'asie de
très bonne culture de champignons
d'ailleurs au bon je voudrais pas que
j'ai loupé une page quand même france
départ économique alors par contre je
crois que la femme de slider est celle
qui a le moins d'endurance du monde
c'est assez impressionnant d'avoir si
peu d'endurance avec tu cours jusqu'à
l'ascenseur à la même peu à quoi déjà
non et on peut aller vers ta pas les
miens j'ai peur je me regarde ailleurs
je sens que je vais crier la cesse et
genre de personne qui vous attend dans
un coin comme ça là
aux jeunes leur jetant une board of her
olalalala voilà déjà déjà essoufflé oh
[ __ ] j'ai cru que j'allais voir faire
mais ya pas de feuilles
[ __ ] je vais non je vais baisser le
chômage ait baissé sur noireau nettement
les gens là j'en ai marre j'en ai marre
je ne sais quoi tu as à eau puis aux
[ __ ] de ta mère au vous l'avez vu oui
une page always be watching cepl au
[ __ ] au [ __ ] ils étaient là bas on
l'a tous vu il était grand comme un
coton tige des runes fait penser aux
monstres day s'est payé un peu plus
méchant un peu du violeur elle est
partout artois lucas nommée gb cinq ans
mais je m'entends mais le plus barré
voilà
c'est trouver d'autres pièces mais ya
quoi comme pièce rare c'est n'importe
quoi avec m ah bah voilà
thomas 4 on a quatre à l'on va gagner là
on va gagner je le sens là je le sens on
va le gagner je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
un pressentiment qui me dit que on voit
au moins en trouver 6 en peluche
absolument aucun sens d'orientation
s'est déroulée place au hasard j'ai sur
mon tu déjà passé par là éventuellement
il va me prendre dans la cave
vingt six länder prendra trois mois ses
nerfs ok on a cinq au [ __ ] ça va vite
ça va vite ça va aller court court allez
hop on avance d'accord c'est un
cul-de-sac cas
sa tête est bizarre et la plainte des
cinq ont été faits sur sneijder qui sont
absolument magnifiques alors 30 ans et
où j'ai adoré bas vous pouvez vous tapez
slender pèsent sur google images par
exemple et vous allez voir qu'il ya
d'écrit vraiment pas mal vous savez un
peu comique et tout franchement moi je
suis bien fan de ça d'ailleurs la russie
s'il y en a qui savent dessiner comme
peut m'envoyer des fois vos dessins
franchement j'adore regarder des dessins
un peu comique bande dessinée ou quoi
honnêtement j'adore ça aa à aa niktamère
excusez-moi par mons et bulgares allez
on met du coup comment je suis je dois
faire tout
tu as live et vénère pas honnêtement
elle est vénère vous a vu j'ai pas eu sa
posture d'homme comme ça
ah ça fait plutôt peur elle sa fille tu
te perds à sa fille tu te perds quatre
ans à notre stand à retirer certains car
tout seul
bon le scénario c'est encore payen tu me
fais des feuilles on veut gagner
d'ailleurs que tu trouves les buffets
qu'est-ce qui se passera et ce qui là
sont faits on commence à se passe ça
j'ai jamais compris encore c'est bon à
face lender on est sauvé et et
je sens qu'il est en fait c'est ça qui
est insupportable en plus j'ai pas
l'argent c'était pour ça en fait ouais
c'est ça le problème en fait je dirais
de cette version wii
alors là 6 sur 8 ha tu as un droit que
cinq au foirail chirac perd pas mais on
va trouver la sagesse médersas
j'aimerais tellement pas à les consignes
du coach et il en reste quelques unes au
risque du losc 2 on peut le faire je
sais qu'on peut y arriver
honnêtement j'ai juste un peu peur de
monsieur sneijder qui se rapprochent de
nous un grand pomme j'aime pas le bus
qui seront tous là et a même trouvé qu'à
16h sur fun
oh oh oui [ __ ] plus qu'une oie la
salle bien entendu
ça devient super tendu au niveau du son
la [ __ ] [ __ ] ya du vent alors qu'on
est dans un garage et comprend bras il
n'ya pas laisser les fenêtres ouvertes
pour toi il ya une tempête qui
d'ailleurs
oreilles j'ai une boule au ventre je
vais m
moi c'est plus en plus fort aa a pour sa
part pour ça court court court court
aaa à aa
coucou coucou core core core cours ne
rejoint pas notre temps faim ne se
trompe pas il touche les fesses tu là il
touche les frais est remonté à ton
soutien gorge il est là ah non c'est bon
c'est bon on va gagner on va gagner non
machine à laver de merde je vais faire
sa lessive et été aussi dur
sender je vais te battre aujourd'hui il
il
allez vraiment escrimeurs là
les plats il a aussi calmé as fait du
bien en fait tout le bruit la plume
acérée aussi il avait toujours pas
compris
10h02
ouais
mais elle est où cette piteuse feuilles
bailly maître les maladies gaspillage
on s'approche court court
un coup d'état
hélas à ckoi sur l'examen que j'ai dû
contracter les hot d'or parce que j'ai
peur
allez allez mettra star et pique nique
mes lacunes genre ou quoi elle est
sérieux unijambiste elle bornes aussi
mal agi tout faut arrêter
obama surveille la bouger tout seul
à une suite il suit mme koning clinton
bangui jules cède pas aux attentes
infections car oui car et on se retrouve
dans l'autre vidéo avec la version
explique tout de suite si vous voulez
cliquez sur la dotation qui a maintenant
et moi je vais me détendre bas